rio das ist karneval
doch der karneval ist in großer gefahr
durch corona aber auch durch die
mächtigen in brasilien ein stück
außerhalb von rio treffen wird am ihres
mottos die tänzerinnen der sambaschule
portela macht sich bereit für einen
auftritt
[Musik]
karneval ist alles in meinem leben ich
könnte ohne nicht leben
ich liebe was ich tue es ist meine
leidenschaft schon seit ich ganz klein
sind er ist zu meinem lebensinhalt
geworden und ich verdiene mein geld dann
heute endlich mal wieder ein auftritt
allerdings ohne publikum
ein live-video fürs internet ein fast
trotzige abt gegen die arbeitslosigkeit
in der korona krise die hat brasilien
immer noch fest im griff und macht auch
den karneval nächsten februar immer
unwahrscheinlicher
kein karneval das wäre sehr traurig und
es wäre eine katastrophe für unsere
wirtschaft viele menschen haben arbeit
junger dank ich glaube wenn er ausfällt
das wird hart das gilt auch für sie da
sie mit samba auftritten gerade kein
geld verdienen kann
geht sie stattdessen putzen irgendwie
muss ja über die runden kommen auch als
kellnerin arbeitet sie nebenher bei der
müllabfuhr was sie auch schon die samba
tänzerin aus dem armen norden der stadt
ist eine überlebenskünstlerin klar habe
ich angst dass ich mein ganzes leben
lang vom putzen leben müsste dass ich
den samba aufgeben nachdem zu den
schlägt man was ich würde schon schwer
leiden aber klar wenn es nicht anders
geht dann schlage ich mich als putzfrau
durch die hoffnung ist natürlich dass
der karneval zurückkommt karneval in rio
das ist eine lange große tradition und
ein wirtschaftsfaktor
mehr als drei millionen touristen kommen
jedes jahr
der karneval sichert das überleben
zigtausende menschen von der samba
tänzerin bis zum straßenverkäufer und
handwerker
das sambodrom im herzen von rio verweist
doch unter einer zuschauertribüne
verteilt eine initiative mit dem namen
rhythmus der solidarität tüten darin
reis und bohnen zucker und öl
tausende musiker sind gerade auf solche
lebensmittelspenden angewiesen wir
treffen philippe thomas event erster
trommler einer sambaschule er hat durch
corona seine arbeit verloren aber
schlimmer noch auch geliebte menschen
[Musik]
ich habe bereits einen onkel wegen
kuwait verloren und ein anderer onkel
liegt gerade im krankenhaus
niemand rechnet damit dass so etwas mit
einem selbst oder nahestehenden menschen
passiert wenn es dann passiert wird es
einen aus der bahn
es ist sehr traurig die krise trifft die
schwächsten am schlimmsten vor allem die
menschen die mit karneval und kultur zu
tun haben wir erleben hier gerade eine
politik die manche begünstigt und andere
einfach links liegen lässt die politik
neben corona die zweite große gefahr für
den karneval dessen ursprung in der
auflehnung der sklaven gegen die
mächtigen liegt präsident bützow naro
liegt nichts an diesem kulturellen erbe
unter ihm gewinnen die evangelikalen
christen immer mehr an einfluss und die
halten ausgelassenes feiern für
teufelszeug
die stadt rio hat den samba schulen
schon letztes jahr den geldhahn
zugedreht
in den augen der welt ist rio de janeiro
eine fröhliche lockere statt
aber inzwischen ist rio konservativ ein
ultra rechter konservativismus hat hier
wurzeln gefasst und der karneval leidet
darunter sehr das letzte jahr war
bereits ein harter schlag für den
karneval
die cidade do samba die samba stadt im
zentrum rios normalerweise herrscht hier
hochbetrieb arbeitsplatz für hunderte
handwerker eine traumfabrik
wir treffen den wagenbau luciano und die
kostümschneiderin bin ja die seit
monaten ohne beschäftigung und einkommen
sind
sie fordern vom verband der sambaschulen
finanzielle unterstützung für die
arbeitslosen handwerker wir sind in
einem überlebenskampf um die kultur und
die kunst des carnevals zu erhalten
aber wir werden nicht aufgeben denn das
ist unsere geschichte unser schweiß
unser blut wir sind der widerstand
widerstand gegen den schleichenden tod
des karnevals von rio regt sich
besonders in den armen vierteln der
stadt die sambaschule man gera liegt wie
viele andere auch am rande einer favela
die von drogenbanden kontrolliert wird
die menschen hier haben kaum
perspektiven nur die samba schule bringt
etwas hoffnung in das sonst trostlose
viertel auf skelter ist in armut
aufgewachsen
mittlerweile ist sie als fahnenträgerin
der sambaschule eine berühmtheit
um kindern aus der favela eine
perspektive zu geben unterrichtet sie
samba normalerweise kommen um die 20
kinder die pandemie hat auch dieses
projekt gestoppt heute sind nur hier an
und johanna gekommen und zeigen was sie
bereits gelernt haben
[Musik]
das ist die kunst die hier in brasilien
an großen unterschied macht sie kann
leben retten
wir sind hier damit die kinder verstehen
welche bedeutung das hier auch für ihr
leben haben kann dass ihre zukunft eine
andere sein kann
genauso wie sich auch mein leben zum
besseren verändert hat karneval in rio
das ist mehr als ausgelassenes feiern
ein ventil für den frust in einer stadt
die von extremer ungleichheit geprägt
ist
es war der karneval der die tief
gespaltene gesellschaft brasiliens für
ein paar magische momente versöhnen ja
vereinen konnte
ein rio ohne karneval das wäre eine
andere stadt
unvorstellbar noch
[Musik]